you know
six years ago we were on the stage with
you at the 2014 game awards
accepting the game of the year for
dragon age inquisition
and since then we've been imagining new
ways to use next generation technology
to bring the world and characters of
dragon age to life
we're still in early production but we
thought it was time to give you the very
first look
at how bioware's passionate team of
developers are crafting this very
special game
[Music]
i've been a borrower for a really long
time so i've got to see it grow up and
turn from
from a company of 35 people to a company
of more than 300 people
there's amazing people in the industry
there's amazing stories to be told with
other people
i love that character so much
we're very experimental here at bioware
so we're always coming up with new stuff
we're always trying to improve
innovate and bring new characters to
life for our players and fans to enjoy
the world of dragon age really has got
it all
it's got frontier stories it's got
mystery
it's got hard-boiled detective stories
and of course it's all wrapped up in
kind of a fantasy setting
you really feel like you're the hero in
the dragon age world and
you're saving people dragon age to me
is a wonderful world to play in
i am really excited about the future of
dragon age
this is an original world original flora
original wildlife original architecture
that makes it fun to explore and
discover
in the next dragon age we get an
opportunity to to see new things new
places
and interact with people who lived and
grew up in these spaces as well
for the game we're working on now we
want to tell a story what happens when
you don't have power
what happens when the people in charge
aren't willing to address the issues
the things that you can expect in the
next installment are going to be stories
that focus on the people around you
and the friends and family you make
something that we'll be able to look
forward to in dragon age
is a really close relationship with game
characters who really become real for
you
we want characters to either be loved or
hated one of the best examples of that
is solas
half the community wants to kill him
half the people want to marry him then
another part want to do both
they call me the dread wolf
what will they call you when this is
over
bioware and ea has been one of the
forerunners in using
motion magic technology and that makes
it way more realistic when you're
looking at the characters and the way
they walk
and move and interact in the world
players wanting that suspension of
disbelief that this
wonderful collection of digital pixels
is actually a living breathing soul
no no it's okay that's the good kind of
rumble
i actually designed bosses i help with
the creature design team as well so i do
all like the big threats that you have
to go up against
nobody dies on my watch for the wardens
choice is a big part of what dragon age
is as a franchise
the decisions you make can affect change
in the world decision
making can mean that a party member
lives or a party member
dies and it means owning your outcome
and
reactivity to the choices that you do
make
i just love the possibilities that
dragon age offers us and i'm excited to
explore a lot more of them
to me that potential is what gets you up
in the morning
it's a fantastic opportunity
every time
you